To be able to recognize when a player wins a game of Tic Tac Toe,
you'll need to tell the computer what a winning Tic Tac Toe grid looks like.
In the code you've been given,
the Tic Tac Toe grid is a three by three 2D array of characters
that keeps track of where or if an XO has been played.
When you first start a game,
the grid has nine empty spots and as you play,
the spots fill up with the symbols X and O.
So at any time,
a spot can either be empty,
have an X in it or have an O in it.
And in our code, the grid array keeps track of
these three possibilities with three different characters.
An empty spot is represented by the dash character,
and X's and O's are just their own lower case letter,
and each character in this grid is stored in an index in our 2D array.
This top left empty character is at the pair of indices
0,0 and to access this character value in code,
you write grid 0,0.
So right now, grid at the index
0,0 is equal to a dash character because it's an empty spot.
And right next to this spot is grid 1,0 and grid 2,0.
And these are also dash characters because this whole row is empty.
But if there was an X at the index 2,0 instead,
then grid 2,0 would equal the X character.
Now, what about these other spots?
Well, the spot right below 0,0 is 0,1.
Can you guess what the indices will be for this bottom left corner?
This pair of indices will be 0,2,
and you might be noticing a pattern.
To access the character at any position in this grid,
we can basically treat these indices as X,Y coordinates.
But in programming, instead of using x and y,
it's common to use i and j.
So, let's say we have integer variables
i and j that are coordinate positions in our grid.
So for the pair of indices,
grid i and j,
i keep track of which column we're in in our array,
0, 1 or 2.
Counting from left to right.
And j keeps track of which row we're in,
counting from top to bottom.
Again, 0, 1 or 2.
So, the center spot of a grid is at the index 1,1 and
the bottom right corner is grid 2,2 and so on for the rest of the characters in our grid.
They're at the index i, j.
So right now, grid 1,1 and grid 2,2
are equal to the dash character because they're empty spots.
But say there's an O symbol here.
Then grid 2,2 this bottom right corner,
will be equal to the character O.
Let's get more practice visualizing a 2D array like this.